Kim Kardashian and Kanye West let go of
their longtime bodyguard
after Kim's traumatizing robbery at
gunpoint in Paris last month sources
confirmed to ET the couple has relieved
Pascal do the heir of his duties for the
family one source tells ET quote Pascal
along with a couple other security
members of their team were recently let
go by Kim and Kanye it's a pretty tough
situation overall and they love Pascal
but they couldn't take any more chances
it was really tough for me a source
previously told ET Pascal was not with
Kim during the robbery he and a driver
dropped him off at her apartment through
the garage and Pascal went out with her
older sister Kourtney who met up with
their younger sister kendall Jenner
another source told ET Kim and Kanye
were quote reassessing their security
detail after the incident went down
Pascal had been the family's bodyguard
for years and we often see him
protecting them on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians ET spoke with a former
bodyguard of kim and kanye's last month
where he expressed he didn't feel the
couple's security team was up to par I
think they need to reevaluate their
structure I think everybody look too
comfortable and I just thinks they have
to hopefully this was a wake-up call
thank god she's okay